hello everybody welcome to another
business Q&A while we play League of
Legends super excited to be here with my
fellow co host as usual Rishi kept TV
welcome aboard hello believe nation how
are you guys today happy Wednesday
what's in your cup believe nation I like
it that's a bit some quality energy on a
Wednesday morning I'm feeling it what's
in your cup today Rishi us what we want
to know yes well I've got my i'm on a
spanish coffee roll this week i've been
really disappointed with my coffee
options these days and so right now
whatever spanish coffee it looks like
you got something red and your cup
what's that the diamond water yeah this
is my vine I'm a little late and
drinking it usually I usually have it
done before nap but yes this is the
vitamin water that Nina makes me every
morning yay yeah so um and then I'm
filling the today I'm just filling the
cup of love the fact that I'm on this
AMA and ma let's play and play ama I
don't know if that's the official name
but I'm just I love that I get to be
here and just have a great time that's a
huge huge blessing so thank you oh I
love it well it's great to have you here
too it's all it's a tender moment here
uh Oh J reyez is with us here as usual
in the in the game I don't know where
trainer 6 is today but it's mean J so
we're setting up a game I'm feeling like
I'm gonna maybe play eve again I don't
know we had a good game yesterday I
don't know we'll see we'll see what
happens when we get in we'll see what
happens well while we wait anything
actually quick shout out to the people
watching in the
live chat on twitch regards a no de
masta Jen so much I know it's early for
Gen 6 15 on the west coast in the
morning so feelin the love joining in
she wants to celebrate with us today and
let's get into it so what's our what's
our first question love it first
question comes from norbert and right no
bro no bro was the one that we week i
washed yesterday because the game ended
and I wanted to give appropriate I
didn't want to rush through the Norbert
answer so I'm liking this we had waiting
some good time for Norbert today feeling
the love for Norbert yeah so he said he
read on your profile that you were at 22
years old vc venture capitalist and he
basically read about the success that
you had and he wanted to know if you
were involved still with vc and if so
he's seeking your advice on securing
funds through venture capitalism and if
you're not involved anymore how he says
how or to whom could you refer me i need
to raise funds for my business ideas
yeah great thanks for the question
norbert and we have a really great
episode that you should definitely check
out number five of these league of
legends live streams if you go back to
that episode you will hear a lot of
in-depth feedbacks from evan
specifically on investment and how to go
about that and one thing that I remember
though evan is that you can find venture
capitalists just from you know getting
to know people in your local area they
could be your dentist they could be your
accountant they could be just people
that you may already know who our
venture capitalists and
even if they're not the right person to
go to for your business they might be
able to point you in the right direction
so I kind of start finding out if
there's anyone in your area that you may
already know who is also a venture
capitalist yeah I got into the venture
capital business I'm not in any more but
I was in it because i told my first
business i was curious about raising
capital it wasn't a skill that that I
really needed to use we never raise
capital for my own business it was all
bootstrap dick only capital e raised was
from our customers by selling products I
so it was really curious interesting
about it we thought about it and I just
I felt like I wanted to learn the
business we will understand the ropes
and how deals were made um I connected
with a guy who was an angel investor I'm
just I don't even know how he met
probably had an event somewhere and he
was part of a venture capital firm and
so he brought me in and that's how I
kind of got my my start there I was
there for a couple years two years maybe
three years i think more two years and
again just wanted to go and learn and
the lesson there too for everybody is
that there's something that you want to
learn just go and find a way to do it I
didn't go the traditional course of you
know starting as an intern or you know
however you might work your way up in a
venture capital firm I had something
else that was a value to bring that I
already sold the business and i found my
unique kind of path in in terms of
raising capital it depends on how much
you need VCS you looking at you know
three hundred fifty thousand dollars
plus really half a million plus really a
million-dollar plus is like that's where
they want to be they don't want to do
the small deals you have to have a
business that that can return thirty
percent return on investment per year by
the time that they sell and they want to
be out you know in five six years they
want to see the
you can go public or you're going to get
acquired really just those two you're
going to go public you're going to get
acquired it's because they want to exit
from your business they want to be with
you for the long haul so not very many
businesses fit that model and most VCS
are not very early stage friendly either
they want to see that you have some
momentum already built up so first is
really understanding where you're at
because I think a lot of people go to a
VC way too early or theyre not the right
kind of business if you don't have if
you don't have users you don't have
customers you don't have you don't you
just have an idea it's too soon don't go
you're going to waste most your time and
most people go away too soon and just
spin their wheels if you are one of that
like tiny percentage of people that are
actually ready to go and have the right
model then it's really just figuring out
which we see has the right fit like who
has money who just recently raised
around you can look like you can just
follow tech quadrature just read the
tech blogs and figure out which vc has
just raised money you can look at which
one's a lot of VC is like to target
different industries so I you know I
want to target these kinds of businesses
in this kind of industry where they
raised a specific fund for specific kind
of venture you want to look at their
portfolio companies can you help plug
our do they have it have they already
made an investment in a company that you
can help that company grow as well you
guys can help each other out there's
there's a positive relationship they're
all of those things are pretty relevant
and then are you willing to potentially
move you know if your VC is in
California are you willing to move to
California to to make this business fly
or not it's not that hard to get on a
radar of a VC if you have a good deal
most people just don't have a good deal
most people's deals are not VC ready and
so they don't
that's what I got good luck nice got a
shout out to off the sourcebook in the
chat sherry welcome back yeah loving the
loyola believe nation coming to this
chat here yeah build it up i like it so
happens when you do something
consistently momentum bandit yes all
right um next question comes from mon
know what yeah mon yeah so i have i have
an idea for an app to develop and a
mindset I don't know how to get it down
or to direct that to lead me to success
you're a white person I hope you can
suggest to reach my greater version of
myself all right um yeah so we got yeah
yeah sorry he is an app and a mindset
that he wants to develop yes okay I'm
not sure if it's the app is about
developing a mindset or he's just asking
for your help with his mindset because
it sounds like he wants to be successful
and he says you're a wise person though
okay you must definitely be able to help
a bit and yes so we had also just had a
lot of questions about apps but just the
immediate thing that comes to mind is if
you have an idea for an app do you have
experience yourself for developing this
app from a tech standpoint if not you
know anyone who is a developer because
obviously you have you might have a
great idea but you have to start
actually making the app so you know I
think that would be
first place I would just say if you
can't develop the app yourself you're
gonna have to find someone who can but
also anything and in terms of like how
can you do this successfully is going to
start by having a great app so you know
I would just put all my focus in all my
energy once you have a developer to make
the appt really really good because
we've talked a lot about how there's a
lot of apps out there that just are not
good yeah I agree we've done we've
talked a lot about apps i guess i'm on
this stream in the past oh yeah i'm just
thinking about the mindset part of the
question and i'm trying to figure out
what he meant by that i don't the app
like help sit with the mindset or he
needs a better mindset to help him get
to what he wants to do so that part is a
little it's confusing but i wanna i
wanna i want to try to help them with
that so in terms of the app the advice
rishi gave is great I agree hundred
percent you've got a you've got to find
someone who can code it for you if
that's not you and you need to do
something that is so great that people
can't wait to use it and tell their
friends and come back and use it again
and again and again and again so many
people focus just on is it supplies that
not just the app business but some
people focus I'm just trying to get new
customers if they don't focus on amazing
their existing customers where if you
made something that was so amazing look
at look at Toronto dance also most of
our business who's my voice was my
business comes from referrals word of
mouth like you you can't afford to go
out and take out super bowl commercials
and you know expensive ad campaigns and
all that stuff so the one of the best
ways to build the business is just by
word of mouth by providing an amazing
service or product that people want to
come back
to and use again and again and again and
tell their friends about so especially
in an app you want something that
they're going to load every day like
make it so good that they're gonna want
to load it every day in turn to the
mindset one of the things that really
helped me in terms of my mindset
development was was the channel like
watching these famous entrepreneurs
these successful people these athletes
paying attention to them and seeing what
what they're doing that I'm not that
maybe I can learn something from I've
always found that to be super helpful
and I've grown in confidence i I've
grown in my you know in my mind set I
just posted a video this morning at
midnight last night this morning what is
midnight I guess it's kind of both i was
twenty robbins talking about the the
single way to the best way to make a
change in your life is to raise your
standards now the fast way to make a
single changing life is you need to
raise your standards and it's classic
tony and he's got is you know is
excitement game on and you know bringing
the heat and bring in the fire bring any
energy and it's great to be reminded of
those messages and I think the more you
surround yourself with people resources
ideas that continue to reinforce the
messages that you maybe even know are
true but don't you don't practice just
like like gratitude you have to practice
it daily you may know that you need to
raise your your standards but have you
actually gone out and done it right or
maybe today you're falling a little bit
short so the more you hang around people
who are of a you know negative mindset
or defeat of defeatist mindset or you
know aren't really the right people for
you it's gonna it's gonna it's going to
not be great where the more you can
spend your time around people who do
have a great mindset a mindset that you
want a model and learn from
the better that's going to be for you
and you know I came from a place so I
didn't really have a lot of people
entrepreneurs in my life that I could
model and so that's why I turned to
books and videos and resources though if
you're worried about improving your own
mindset or if you're trying to develop
an app that improve somebody's mind set
I would really focus in on giving them
those access giving them that access to
people resources ideas that can make
them make them the best version of
themselves you know that constant daily
reminder that they need to do they need
to do better you need to keep pushing
harder yeah it makes me think about to I
was thinking if you're talking about
that all the times I've had a major
change in a mindset and there's been one
common theme every single time which is
interesting because I just realized this
very similar to what you are just
sharing every single time I was kind of
broken through quote unquote there was a
teacher and it could have been like a
literally a teacher like in academia or
just someone that I saw on TV or a video
I watched and they they just it always
required a person kind of as a catalyst
to bring me to that new place and into
that in your mindset so I think anyone
wants to change of mindset I think
you're going to it will require to you
know someone else has already been there
and can kind of pull you in that
direction you know what metaphorically
speaking yeah I think I think a great
skill to improve on is your observation
skills and learning through osmosis it's
something that it's something at which
i'm working on here with Alex who's part
of me who are part of me part of trying
to 10 salsa and one of the things that
we're working on for all the instructors
making them bed
better teachers and not just not just
better dancers and knowing how to do
salsa but better teachers and be able to
connect with people better and so you
know he's watching videos of people who
do a good job of speaking and connecting
and I sent him the link to a channel
called charisma on command and what
charisma on command is all about is
breaking down successful people have
charisma whether it's kevin hart or
robert downey jr people of charisma and
breaking down what makes them so
charismatic i guess to say mm-hmm and
it's it's a lot easier it's easier
because it he breaks it down right
there's the teacher right the teacher
breaks it down for him where the next
skill to learn is okay how do you how
can you watch Kevin Hart or what were
these people are and learn from them
yourself having the observational skills
to learn from them and say oh look at
how Kevin did that instead of only being
entertained to be able to learn from it
it's something I'm trying to do for
myself too when I look at you know les
brown or Tony Robbins sometimes they
break it down for you sometimes it's
super clear and easy but other times you
need to kind of watch what they're doing
and figure it out for yourself as well
and the more you can develop those
observational skills like it's some of
you gravitate to there's an entrepreneur
or athlete or inventor or somewhere that
you just respect think about why you
respect them and what what you can model
from them because they may not break it
down like you may love Elon Musk and you
may really respect him you may want to
you know be the Elon Musk of your
industry but there's no you know Ilan
doesn't break you down say here's how to
be Elon Musk and there may be a
presentation that maybe you know
something out there that somebody else
has done and maybe varying levels of
quality but if you can start to learn
how you can model success on your own
from these people it'll make a
tremendous difference in your life so
cold we've got some people Advent gem so
much says also you know you can not just
learn from by a teachers but learn from
teaching yourself like you being a
teacher is also a way that you can learn
and grow in your mindset and then just a
great discussion about how there's you
can have virtual mentors which is so
true Evan I've never met you and I
consider you one of my mentors very cool
so yeah get your virtual mentor all
right how's the game going ah team is
losing hard we are two and eight I have
one kill so that's a good start but I
will to die this my team will clean up
yeah it's good yeah it's it's it's a
rough start but we'll see we'll see you
gotta yesterday it was too but you kept
saying you know you're gonna win so
you've got to keep saying that yeah we
got it we got it we'll see I'm excited
yeah Jay died in the right we'll see
we'll see we'll see what happens let's
keep helping entrepreneurs okay next
question comes from Lou Tendo and I'm
all right i just got a squirrel thought
of Nintendo Lou Tendo I'm 16 years old
and I've been wanting to draw some dress
oh okay I'm 16 years old and I want to
draw a dress but I have to start drawing
and I want a company that can draw my
dresses what should I do okay the she's
its designer aspiring designer wants to
start her
and he or him I don't know the girl or
guy but wants to draw dresses and wants
a company to basically make the dresses
that he or she designed yeah I think
first thing I would just say is it's
really easy to be really excited to do
something and then to want to kind of
not learn the whole aspect of the
business it's not like in my in my case
with with YouTube like I don't have an
aspiring an aspiration to be an amazing
videographer or a video editor but it's
part of the business of what I am doing
and so in the very beginning I am doing
you know what I have to do to start and
just be you're talking about building
momentum earlier so I don't I think it's
too soon at 16 years old old not not not
because of the age because you're in the
very beginning it's too soon to want to
then have a company just start you know
working for you to make the dresses that
you want to design at this stage I think
you should want to learn how to sew and
to create the dresses that you design
not to do it forever but because i don't
know one designer out there that that
does it professionally that doesn't
themselves know how to create their work
themselves so i would not say go out
there and try to find somebody to make
your dresses i would say how can you
right now start learning how to create
the dresses and you know later when you
do have money if you do want someone
else to do it for you that's tough fine
but i think it's great for you to have
those skills so you can just begin to
build some momentum
yeah three cheese point it also helps
having just the tertiary knowledge right
it helps to have a baseline standard of
knowledge and know-how something is done
so you can not necessary ticket but you
know as an example I'm not a programmer
but I can I can talk to programmers I
know enough about how program is done
that I can i can get by and not that i
would ever tell a programmer that you
know you're doing it wrong and you got
to do it this way or something like that
but whoa i died very sad but i can i can
have a conversation with a programmer
where I can translate the business
problem that I'm having into what i need
the programmer to do which is definitely
very helpful and it only started because
when i when i was first getting my
website off the ground I didn't I didn't
I couldn't afford a programmer and so I
had to figure it out for myself I had to
start learning how to kind of program
and scrap together things to make it
work if you really don't want to learn
how to sew and you feel like this is
just a terrible use of your time then
you don't have to go right to a big
company it could be it could be another
student who was like you and wants to
whoa can I get whoa crap I am gonna die
I jumped into something very dangerous
yeah it doesn't have to be a big company
i mean the fear the fear that I have the
honest fear like it's good to try to
share yourself with resources people
companies that that can complement your
weaknesses the fear I have is that
you're not going to get started and this
happens to a lot of people like I need
to have a company make my dresses and
until that happens I can't do anything
and that that thought process manifests
itself in a lot of different ways I need
to get you know I need to get invested
investment money before I start or I'm
not going to be successful or I need to
have you know this business partner
lined up for I won't be successful
whatever it is right we all tell
ourselves this story oh that's my
biggest concern and this question is
that he or she is not going to actually
go and do something because they're just
so you're not having that big company
come on and support them and so in our
own way we should I both trying to tell
you that you have to find a smaller way
to get started you have to find a
smaller way whether that's figuring out
how to do it yourself or working with
another student or whatever it may be
you have to figure out a way to just get
it started and still have that big goal
of working with that working with a big
company that's awesome but you need to
find a way to get started right now so
you start building momentum and it may
not be perfect and it's not it's not
what you want and the quality level
won't be where you know it can be but
getting something out now and build the
momentum toward something bigger is much
more valuable than just sitting back and
waiting for the perfect thing to come
around that's what do you got that it
good luck with endo yes agree to it next
next question is coming and Tom it is
asking dear Evan I'm trying to get the
job but how to get it easily I'm also
trying to do my best and outsourcing
she's trying to get a job looks like and
he wants your feedback on how to get one
easily and I'm trying to do my best and
outsourcing I guess well I'll go into
that in a second the first thing i'll
just say about you know if you have an
opportunity to get help for something
like a job search the first place that
you need to start is what do you want I
don't know if you mean you want to be an
outsourcing like you want to be you know
working for a company that they are
outsourcing their employees or if you're
saying you are also asking a question
about you know outsourcing in your
potential business I think it might mean
the first but yeah it's hard to answer
this question if you don't have any idea
about what you want Tommy what do you
want to do what are your goals and if
you don't know a great great place to
start would be just like what would you
know what really is something that
you're passionate about what are your
skill what experiences have you had so
far in your life but yeah you really
when it comes to job searches just
there's you first need to just start
with what do you want to do yeah i mean
i agree if you want to stand out in it
in a job application so this isn't jen
because i'm just hi I'm going through
the process of looking at someone for
Charlie I salsa right now and most
people what they submit is so bored
mmm-hmm and really understanding what a
company is all about and doing a little
bit of extra homework whether it's
making a video for them whether it's
trying to you know message them on
social media and support some of the
projects that they're all about like
most people just do the bare minimum and
they mail in the job application which
is a huge it's just so it's frustrating
how people male in the job search like
if you really want something you better
work hard to show yourself please prove
yourself stand out and it doesn't take a
lot because most people do so little
that standing out is pretty easy oops oh
we're in a fight win a fight we're in a
fight what a fight and I gotta kill very
exciting about that um and so for any of
you who are entrepreneurs who watch this
you're like you know that too that look
at the people who've applied to your
jobs ninety percent of the people are
really just mailing it in and did not do
a any kind of effort that just right
most people just write a cover letter
and they write oh died they write a
cover letter and they write you know
resume is pretty standard stuff and
there's nothing unique about your cover
letter it's the same thing to everybody
maybe you customize the name but that's
not enough to stand out and because so
when people do so little it's only
easier for you to get your chance to
shine so I've been looking at what is it
what is that you really like about this
company why did you pick them and what
else can you do to impress them because
much more important than just having
skills is the mindset and the hustle and
the attitude and the beliefs and the
people see that you are out working hard
I always want to hire that kind of
person the person who I would hire the
participants but has the desire always
over the person who has all the
experience
it looks kind of bored and most people
look forward in their in their resumes
so just show up to show up find a way to
help them yeah and Evan do you would you
say that you are the norm when it comes
to I mean you have some pretty
unconventional videos even on how the
hiring process is broken our company is
hiring like these you think i see like i
see a change in job search trends about
companies wanting people to actually
just be themselves and not try to be
this cookie cutter resume and cover
letter that just seems really you might
have all these accomplishments but it's
just dull and boring would you say as
someone who is a a bot or a company out
there hiring like are you do you find
other people out there like you who are
looking for more personality versus like
just a professional very polished resume
uh that's a interesting question cuz i I
don't feel like I'm the norm in most
things so uh not that it's no better
just not the norm I actually don't think
most people are the norm we just got to
embrace your inner weirdness and do you
so I I don't think that i am a typical
higher I think I do have a different job
hiring process than most people that
being said though every every job every
every company can relate to having
terrible applicants who are boring and
don't stand out and don't make an effort
and don't make a difference everybody
can relate to that and so how I would
appreciate something might be different
than others but we are all still human
beings we all get touched by emotion we
all appreciate hustle and drive and hard
work and so finding a way to be able to
show
off I think is important love it all
right over deliver that value even in
your job application everything in life
over the living life I love that oh
that's a tweetable moment little moment
alright okay alright next question game
looks like it's a little harder bun
they'll believe in this is a rough game
it is very rough I'm doing okay
definitely not my greatest game but
we'll see let's see what happens hanging
in oh we better we got a good question
from our live chat all right good oh
good love for the right chat let's do it
yeah we've got a question from optiv
source book and she's asking Evan what
was the first question that you got
starting out helping entrepreneurs do
you remember what was the first question
that I got ya may be back I don't know
back it when you are at the YMCA or what
was the first question they do you
remember getting uh oh no no I read it
i'm sorry i read it wrong what was the
first question that got you started
helping entrepreneurs the first question
i got me starting helping entrepreneurs
oh I'm gonna die in a day I died um the
first question that got me started
helping entrepreneurs
it's a good question i don't know uh the
the first thing that I oh we surrendered
we lost very sad I didn't surrender my
team surrendered on me we lost I'm very
sad from surrender which is also very
different um anyway i'll just say GG to
everybody um you know i sold my business
and one of the first opportunities that
I got was to go to Mexico to represent
Canada at what was it some economic
forum or something world economic forum
or I don't know feel it was something
like that and i was i was invited to
join the canadian young entrepreneur
teen which i didn't even know we had but
i guess i saw that i had sold the
business and had some success and so
they wanted me to go and be part of the
Canadian delegation to the World Summit
thing and that was that was I think the
first time I got asked to do anything
were where wasn't just being an
entrepreneur where it was trying to help
others or be a speaker or just represent
an idea much more than just running my
own company when I was running my
business I didn't have this aspiration
didn't have this desire a dream or goal
to to help other entrepreneurs I just
was doing my thing when I went to Mexico
I had a great time at a whole bunch of
international entrepreneurs I got
invited them to buy one of the members
there was some Brunei and I got invited
to go speak in Brunei to help their
young entrepreneurs and that was a super
scary moment because it was on national
TV and thousands of people in a room and
by far the biggest thing I've ever done
was the only the second thing I've ever
done public speaking but the biggest as
well and then I just remember thinking
that these are great experiences have
never been to Mexico or Brunei before
that time and I just felt like there's a
lot of people in my country who could
use help to look why do I have to fly
around the world like I should be giving
back to my own community to and helping
them out and that's when I started
that's when I approached the YMCA and
then started putting on some seminars
free workshops to help entrepreneurs and
it just built built and built and built
and built up still without really having
a business model or revenue model around
it I didn't get paid to go to Mexico I
don't think I got paid to go to prune I
I don't think i got paid to go to brunei
I mean they paid for my flight and
everything while I was there but didn't
like make a speaking fee and then I just
kind of fell in love with helping
entrepreneurs it was just something that
I really enjoy doing those three people
that YMCA first session that I did was
was awesome and I just wanted to it was
one of the things that I was testing I
had no idea that I was gonna go I was
testing being in a venture capital
business I was testing salsa dancing I
was testing helping out entrepreneurs I
was test a whole bunch of other stuff
that that most I don't remember what
they were because they'd fallen off the
map a night and they didn't work just
like you know when you're single you got
a bunch of dates and you see what works
I was dating I was trying a bunch of
stuff I was just trying a bunch of stuff
and I didn't know that i really had no
expectations i wanted i thought it would
be like this big I thought it would be a
big event because we produce Oh hard but
I didn't expect to fall in love with it
it was just something that I felt like
coming coming on the plane ride home
from Brunei that I wanted to do
something to help my own you know
country and people and people here not
just around the world and so that's what
led to the ymca thing I didn't know that
I would fall in love with it and that
that would be every month thing that
would lead to a website and lead to a
YouTube chain only to all this stuff i
wish i wish i could say like yes I was
visionary and I knew from the start that
this is how it was
turn out but really it was just testing
a bunch of stuff and seeing what I you
know what I love doing and after that
first YMCA event I actually never
thought I was going to make money I
didn't think it would be a career
opportunity for me because only three
people showed up to a free thing and I
thought if I can only get three people
to come for free how would I ever be
able to make money from this and for me
it didn't matter I loved it so I had to
find a way to keep doing it even if I
had to go if I start another business or
if I got a job or whatever I had to find
a way to keep doing this because I loved
it so much so yeah I didn't have a big
bold vision at the start and I didn't
think I'd make anybody here and here we
are just by continuing to build momentum
continued to keep doing it every single
at that time was every single month and
then making that weekly and then
eventually daily and then you know what
the youtube channel multiple times a day
um boom so I don't know if I answer that
question but i think the mexico thing
was hardly the first invite that i got
that kind of opened my eyes to the world
if I could do something more than just
being entrepreneur could help others
somehow and then the ymca thing here in
Toronto was the was the single event
that kind of changed my like that's when
I fell in love with it and I had to go
and do more and that led to where we are
now so great question well hopefully
that helped yeah and we're all feeling
the love Evan for everything that you do
every day I we got a lot of love in the
chat right now people just say how much
they love this community how positive it
is and definitely tribute to your your
passion and genuine love to just help
entrepreneurs it's the real deal so yeah
you got to find what you love you got a
silent
love ya cool well sad about the loss but
happy about all the questions we were
the ice to not that many questions but I
was hacked with the answer how many did
we get to 3mm five today include
netiquette of the third bug okay bye
okay that's fine that's good i'm happy
with that um great well onion a little
bit early today you guys get some extra
time to go out and crush whatever
business goals you have rishi final
final words final message for the team
yeah it's just a cup of being you and
cup of love what you do all right I love
it go check out rishika TV for lots of
uh what's your tagline good oh no no you
change your tire have you changed i'll
try to member like a diagram of the
tagline just what's in your car yo
what's in your cup check out we should
cut TV to figure out what's in your cup
I love it thank you guys so much for
watching we will see you tomorrow I'm
heading into my video de you guys gave
me some nice energy for that so I'm
really grateful for you that's it
continue to believe whatever your one
word is and we'll see you soon